[Musik]
auch diese nacht wieder fliegeralarm in
der hauptstadt in kiew es soll wieder
mehrere schwere explosionen gegeben
haben
unter anderem ist ein russisches
geschoss neben dem hauptbahnhof
eingeschlagen mindestens ein mensch sei
verletzt worden sein die angriffe sie
nehmen nicht nur in der hauptstadt zu
warum darf kränker direkt jedem kiew
sind zahlreiche wohnhäuser zerstört die
bewohner sagen ein russisches flugzeug
habe kur anchor bombardiert sind
fassungslos
sie könne nicht ohne die ukraine sie
verstehen dass sie ohne die ukraine ein
mann sind die studierte 30 jahre
unabhängigkeit deshalb brechen sie sich
jetzt weil die ukraine nicht freiwillig
und so eine art sowjetunion zurück will
sie will es nicht wir wollen
selbstständig sein
besonders betroffen ist der süden der
ukraine die hafenstädte mario pohl und
rasern maria poll soll über 14 stunden
lang ununterbrochen beschossen worden
seien
die kritische infrastruktur wurde
zerstört
wir sind ohne licht
ohne wasser und ohne heizung
[Musik]
die russischen truppen sollen die hier
straftaten gebiete bereits kontrollieren
auch herr sei ein bewohner berichtet
seitdem ich heute morgen die russischen
panzer gesehen habe habe ich nichts mehr
von den ukrainischen behörden
mitzukommen
keine polizei keine ukrainischen
soldaten mehr ich glaube die stadt ist
jetzt zu 100 prozent unter russischer
kontrolle
der widerstand geht jedoch weiter emilio
topol im süden demonstrieren ukrainische
bürger gegen die russischen besatzer
präsidentiellen appelliert in der nacht
an die russischen streitkräfte die
waffen niederzulegen
die ukraine möchte nicht dass das land
von russischen leichen gedeckt ist
geht nach hause nehmt eure armee mit
sagt euren kommandeur dass er nicht
sterben möchte sondern leben wollte
oberrad ii
eine friedliche lösung scheint in weiter
ferne ein hoffnungsschimmer könnten die
verhandlungen zwischen der ukraine und
russland sein diese sollen heute
nachmittag stattfinden im westen von
belarus ausgang offen
zum besseren verständnis der aktuellen
lage in der ukraine ist uns nun der
forschungsdirektor der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
zugeschaltet christian mölling
schwerpunkte unter anderem militär
rüstung und verteidigungspolitik unter
kämmerling hanno günther wenn sie die
aktuelle lage militär strategisch
bewerten welchen fortgang erwarten sie
erscheint ihnen ein kurzfristiges ende
der gewalt aktuell überhaupt möglich
ich glaube dass wenn mir nichts fehlen
werden wir gesehen dass russland
erhebliche probleme gehabt hat den
letzten tag voran zu kommen jetzt ist es
so weit dass kiew nahezu eingeschlossen
ist mordes frei aber wir haben es mit
einer der größten städte in europa zu
tun mit was über 2,7 millionen
einwohnern das ist in den letzten
jahrzehnten nicht gelungen eine solche
stadt einfach einzunehmen von daher
höchstwahrscheinlich wochen dauern bis
das gelungen bis das gelungen sein
könnte also es wird sehr lange dauern
und ich glaube wir werden noch sehr
lange darüber berichten in austin
schreckliche bilder sehen deutschland
hat nun zugesagt weitere waffen zu
liefern an die ukraine 2700 die
flugabwehrraketen noch aus ddr beständen
welchen militärischen wert hat diese
lieferung
erst mal müssen wir sicher sein dass sie
einen technischen wert haben also
überhaupt funktionieren dahinter gibt es
zurzeit glaube ich ein fragezeichen wenn
ich das richtig sehe wenn man sie
liefern kann und sie einfach einzusetzen
sind dann bedeutet das dass
flugzeuge nicht mehr einfach durch den
ukrainischen luftraum fliegen können
selbst wenn die raketen nicht einfach zu
bedienen sind oder vielleicht nicht so
zielgenau sind ist es trotzdem eine
zusätzliche gefahr für die russischen
streitkräfte die dadurch entsteht das
führt zu einer zusätzlichen verlangsamen
zu weniger freiheit in der bewegung und
das erhöht natürlich letztendlich die
verhandlungsposition verbessert die
führungsposition von sie lynskey
vielleicht nicht in den verhandlungen
die heute möglicherweise stattfinden
aber dann doch in den nächsten wochen
wir müssen auch da zu sehen auch das
gehört mit zu dieser belegungssituation
dazu dass die sanktionen die europäische
union lassen da zusammen mit den
amerikanern
schrittweise anfangen zu greifen das
heißt es kann sein dass wir in zwei drei
wochen neuen situationen sind in der
russland massiv unter druck gerät und
sich möglicherweise dadurch neue
optionen ecke jetzt gibt sich weiß nicht
wie sie es war nebenher meldung hier in
deutschland sehr viele menschen die
einen gewissen zwiespalt sind auf der
einen seite haben sie riesige
hochachtung vor dem mut dem unfassbaren
mut der menschen in der ukraine sich
dieser russischen übermacht
entgegenzustellen und der daraus
resultierende wunsch ihnen zu helfen auf
der anderen seite nehmen natürlich auch
alle die drohungen von putin war die
drogen auch gegen all diejenigen die die
ukraine unterstützung atom drohungen
zumindest indirekt auch gegen staaten
der nato wie groß ist aus ihrer sicht
die gefahr dass sich dieser krieg
ausweitet auf die nato
der krieg weitet sich nur dann aus wenn
die nämlich zusammensteht und wenn wir
die solidarität unter den nato-staaten
nicht halten das heißt also diese
ambivalenz die kann ich auf der einen
seite sehr gut nachvollziehen auf der
anderen seite muss ich aber sagen es
braucht nicht nur ambivalent wenn ich
dann konsequenz nämlich wenn wir sagen
wir haben ein gemeinsames europa wir
haben demokratische staaten da müssen
die sich untereinander helfen und
natürlich gefällt das dem russischen
machthaber nicht und er droht uns ganz
klar aber ich habe hier sollte man
wiederum auf die eigene stärke vertrauen
und eine andere frage ist was finden
europa wollen wir den leben in dem wir
letztendlich staaten die sich
demokratisch verhalten nach westen
wollen im guten und im bus schmeißen
weil wir angst davor haben dass uns 1 1
macht heraus was moskau droht stichwort
konsequenz dazu zu einer politischen
forderung ist mehren sich die stimmen
die sagen ja das ist ein sehr großes
sanktionspaket gegen putin aber
gleichzeitig kauft man weiter von ihm öl
und gas für milliarden finanziert in
damit weiter frankreichs ex präsident
allein zum beispiel sagt jetzt das müsse
enden auch wenn es für uns alle teuer
wird hätte das denn aus ihrer sicht
große wirkung auf putin
also der erdgas sektor sind die beiden
bereiche
putin am meisten aus dem export in die
europäische union verdient von daher ja
das stimmt wir haben andere länder die
ähnlich in einer ähnlichen situation
sind wie die usa wir können die
abhängigkeit von russischen lieferungen
nicht einfach reduzieren das dilemma
situation in die wir über die jahre
hinweg durch leistungen von politikern
ehemaligen politikern hinein gerutscht
sind das jetzt auch einmal aufzuführen
führt glaube ich auch nicht zum ziel
denn wenn in berlin und anderswo die
wohnungen kalt sind dann habe ich gegen
unterstützung verdienen können als ich
möglicherweise anlass kommt also von
daher kann ich das schon verstehen diese
forderungen aber sie kommen natürlich
aus regionen die davon soll diesen
forderungen oder den konsequenzen der
forderung nicht direkt betroffen werden
anordnung von dr christian welling
forschungsdirektor der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik
vielen dank
ich danke ihnen und wir schauen direkt
weiter nach paris einer der wenigen wenn
ich der einzige westliche regierungschef
der soweit bekannt derzeit regelmäßig
direkt mit wladimir putin kommuniziert
ist frankreichs präsident immer neue
makro thomas weide ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet thomas vorhin haben die
beiden erneut miteinander telefoniert
heißt es was kann sie berichten
ja der elysée bestätigt dass die
präsidentin account putin heute
anderthalb stunden miteinander
telefoniert hätten anschließend habe man
den ukrainischen präsidenten syriens die
angerufenen zu inhalten hat der élysée
bislang sich nicht geäußert gestern
abend in seiner fernsehansprache hatte
gaddafi angekündigt dass er den dialog
mit putin fortsetzen wolle und vor
kurzem hat der élysée erhalten verlauten
lassen wie man sich das denn
vorzustellen habe zunächst einmal seien
sämtliche kontakte abgesprochen mit den
verbündeten und auch mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten syriens geht
das heißt der élysée will den eindruck
vermeiden dass dass sie einen alleingang
von makros sei in den gesprächen mit
putin gestern robus zu so heißt es die
beiden würden sich frank und frei dort
ihre meinung sagen niemand gebe dort
seine standpunkte auf aber so sagte der
élysée putin höre sich das alles an und
spreche dort ohne aufgeregtheiten ohne
gereiztheit man gehe dort sachlich aber
deutlich miteinander um der grund warum
man das alles mache sei er wolle putin
handlungsoptionen zeigen er wolle ihm
aufzeigen dass zu jeder zeit der
entwicklung putin die möglichkeit habe
auch anders zu entscheiden zu
deeskalieren
der élysée sagt das sei kein einfacher
dialog aber ein notwendiger
informationen von thomas weiter live aus
paris vielen dank und
nun unser gesprächsgast der ukrainische
botschafter in deutschland andrej melik
vielen dank dass sie bei uns sind
gutendorf unzen herr botschafter die
erbarmungslosigkeit der russischen
angriffe nimmt offenkundig täglich zu
fuß werden kranken krankenhäuser
beschossen versorgungswerke strom wasser
haben sie hoffnung dass die
verhandlungen heute zumindest zu einer
vorübergehenden waffenruhe führen
in der tat wir haben jetzt mit dem
brutalsten blutigsten kriege in europa
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg zu tun und
deswegen muss dieses blutvergießen so
schnell wie möglich beendet werden wir
hoffen dass das diese gespräche fruchten
werden auch wenn diese hoffnung
vielleicht nicht so hoch ist wie wir
erwarten dass das die vermittler und
deutschland bleibt nach wie vor eine der
beiden vermittler mit frankreich in
diesem sogenannten normandie format da
sie sich jetzt einschalten und auf
händchen einwirken damit mindestens eine
eine waffenruhe eingesetzt wird der
mitte die toten die fäden toten geborgen
werden können damit die verletzten
versorgt werden und damit auch die
städte die städte die großstädte die
kleinen kommunen die zerbombt werden die
zerstört werden damit auch sie jetzt
sogar bekommen zu den lebensmitteln zur
wasser der mit der stromversorgung
wieder hergestellt wird das alles
verläuft vor unseren augen unter diesen
ausmaß hätte ich mir und meine
landsleute nicht in dem schlimmsten
alter vorstellen können also vor diesen
verhandlungen immer dass putins
forderungen seien unter anderem die
sogenannte entmilitarisierung der
ukraine und die abtretung der krim an
russland die ukraine lehnt das
entschieden ab wenn sie unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern erklären
können warum ist etwa diese sogenannte
entmilitarisierung für die ukraine
überhaupt keine option
schauen sie für uns ist gar keine option
zugeständnisse zu machen denn
keines von diesen zugeständnissen würde
herrn brötchen zufrieden stellen ganz im
gegenteil er würde nur weiterhin quasi
damit bestärkt dass seine politik von
ultimaten seine politik von von diesen
blutigen krieg erfolge zeigt deswegen
wir sind wir bleiben und wir werden auch
ein souveräner staat sein das bedeutet
ein staat hat die regierung hat die
bevölkerung das staatsgebiet und eine
armee deswegen sind all diese
forderungen vom anfang lange unerfüllbar
ob es um die entmilitarisierung geht
oder um die entnazifizierung geht also
wie kann man sich mitte vorstellen in
einem land wo der präsident ein jude ist
und zu hause russisch spricht deswegen
all das was herr putin verlangte ist aus
der luft gegriffen von man sah man
deswegen man man sollte weiterhin
standhaft bleiben und vor allem jetzt
dafür alles tun um den menschen zu
helfen wie gesagt waffenruhe diese
beschlüsse unbedingt einstellen dem
roten kreuz zugang ermöglichen also für
die verletzten für die um die toten zu
bergen gefangenenaustausch das alles ist
jetzt das was an erster stelle liegt und
nicht darüber zu spekulieren welche
neuen forderungen der kriegsverbrecher
putin letzte aufstellt dann würde
deutschland haben kann angesprochen
weitere waffen liefern 2700
flugabwehrraketen das wird den
widerstand stärken den widerstand ihrer
landsleute der weltweit viel bewunderung
findet dennoch die russische armee
bleibt ja was die ausrüstung betrifft
trotzdem sehr weit überlegen wird dieser
russische vormarsch auf kiew am ende
überhaupt militärisch zu stoppen sein
schauen sie hätten hätte die ukraine vor
vier jahren gleich nach der kremation
mit mit waffensystemen
versorgt werden beliefert werden können
dann dann hätten wir vielleicht den
krieg in syrien aber auch nicht diesen
krieg heute vor augen gehabt deswegen ja
es ist jetzt viel zu spät dass diese
waffenlieferungen kommen aber die sind
trotzdem sehr wichtig also für die arme
wir haben jetzt über hunderttausende
freiwillige die sich gemeldet haben wir
haben eine internationale legion mit
jetzt schon 6000 kämpfer die schon in
der ukraine sind und die auch der armee
und
verteidigung helfen werden deswegen ja
wir sehen diese über machte aber wie
gesagt man sollte auch diese überwachte
putins nicht überschätzen wir haben
gesehen dass ist er achter tagen dieses
blutigen krieges die ukraine ist immer
noch da steht fest der präsident ist in
der hauptstadt die menschen sind bereit
weiterhin ihre heimat ihre hauptstadt zu
verteidigen und es kommt es nicht darauf
an zu warten oder abzuwarten bis dieser
krieg so schnell wie möglich zu ende
geht bis die ukraine in die knien
gezogen es sondern es geht jetzt darum
dass weitere neue lieferungen an
waffensystemen an verteidigungswaffen in
der ukraine ankommen um eben die
menschen die bleiben viele sind jetzt
wie vor sind gefroren das ist sehr
schade aber die meisten ukraine und wir
sind 40 minuten menschen die bleiben die
verteidigen ihre städte ihre kommunen
ihre wohnblöcke und deswegen deswegen
ist es auch jetzt nicht so spät nicht zu
spät massiv weiterhin uns mit diesen war
von systemen zu helfen die liste liegt
dem verteidigungsministerium heute
werden wir eine neue liste zu kommen
lassen mit der bitte das uns so schnell
wie möglich geholfen wird sehr deutliche
worte und appelle des ukrainischen
botschafters in deutschland andrej melik
herzlichen dank für das gespräch ich
danke den bund